reporting live from the end of CES this
happened two days ago this episode
babban and I were just walking and he
said to me [ __ ] dude I don't think we
could put any of it out there was so
much important information like secret
information it was just something we
couldn't put out so you know that's good
A's episode bottom line is like some
days it just [ __ ] works out that hey
enjoy it hey guys CES 2018 off to a good
start so good meetings
Andreea and so it's going well we're
going to a dinner party right now that
we put on and little wine little senior
executives a little networking and then
the media link party which I'm not sure
I'm going to go to last night was a
pretty exciting night do not understand
if I lose tonight it's even better so I
don't sleep actually out of just
excitement which never happens so I'm
gonna try to get some rest cause it's a
long week but I'll sneak in there real
quick kiss some babies it's I'm gonna
get mobbed this week so see ya how are
the kids that one's good good holiday
you have changed his life really truly
so awesome not knowing that we work and
I know I know it's been following you
you really yes yes I said to me Mom do
you know Gary Vee yes I remember the
story okay
and now he writes not like Gary Vee on
his LinkedIn
as I said I love it it's like something
like that like below he's not the
garyvee status yet but I got to tell you
watch out his way cuz he's better
clothes you better get that punch ow
let's go Babs yeah but now it's it's a
it's a an educated confidence you know
yeah and so it's really quite remarkable
you know you got a bottle that'd be so I
I really cannot thank you enough it
makes me super happy but listen you know
we can create the framework but it takes
their dance it takes them to take
advantage of it you know he did we are a
partnership dinner with the female
quotient Shelly Salas is one of the most
interesting and dynamics yeah executives
that I know in the game and Vayner X
pure well and vaynermedia have teamed up
with FQ the female quotient of the girls
lounge all her incredible energy on most
important issues like you know equality
not only on the female skill but just
life just incredibly fascinating the end
of that I've gotten to know over the
last five years who I have a warm Sun
respect for sharp as a tack heart of
gold
big-time green just love her energy
character where'd you see her puffy pink
coat but nonetheless we're gonna be a
little fireside chat here and talk about
the quality issues in the marketing
world as we see across the world and how
do you not over pander how do you not
under pain or just should be a great
question to a great group and and I like
these kind of small dinners we get to
think and that's what tonight would be
about I think you know a the thing
that's been running through my mind
quite a bit around change is respectful
disrespect
right so you know you were talking about
this this is a true scene we actually
have it on film in the back room before
to started we're talking about the main
stage at CES and you know the issues
that I'm sure we'll get to tonight and I
literally asked Shelly I'm like where is
the main stage what is the main stage
I've been coming to see us for six years
I've never gone to the conference I
didn't know there was a main stage at
CES until
my friends texted me about like let's
break the mainstage right and and and in
that moment back there I'm like it's
respectful disrespect I'm not
disrespecting CS I'm not mad at the
status quo
I'm just not spending any time on it
because the only way you can change is
when you don't accept what's already
been accepted
you've just only focused on one thing
which is the reality of the marketplace
the end consumer or whatever you're
doing for a living so for me I think you
know listen when you're an entrepreneur
you don't have somebody judging you the
results judge you and so maybe it's been
easier for me than a lot of you that are
executives so I have a lot of empathy to
that but I do think that respectful
disrespect is what comes to mind the
making change which is I'm fascinated by
people looking backwards because nothing
that happened yesterday is what gets you
to the next place except the thematics
but the details in the execution changes
so you know to me that when we were
talking about this I asked you who picks
the people for the panel like it this
stuff is so simple people I have a lot
of CEOs who always like a mad at my a
madam I salespeople and I asked her well
changed her bonus structure you can get
any salesperson to do anything you want
in the world by making the bonuses
reflect what you want to happen if you
want to do more Facebook stuff make an
arbitrary bonus that if you do seven
Facebook things you receive 80% of your
bonus and then everybody will do that
and so for me I think we shouldn't even
talk about this tonight I think we need
to figure out who's picking it and
mandate and move on there's been a lot
of conversation I don't want to see
controversy but a lot of conversation
with CES this year on women on the
mainstage I think you've all seen a lot
of press and more importantly a lot of
tweets around it and people kind of
arguing about why this and why that
and so Stephen has been you know
instrumental with um and CPS interacted
so I want to thank all of our mazing
partners
well like I I agree 100% I love the
concept what we're gonna do is go around
we're gonna give you a little bit of
time to think about this but this is not
about four to seven or eleven people
getting up here and taking the mic when
you look at the pedigree of everybody in
this room whether in the beginning of
their career or later in it everybody
here has something to add so we're gonna
go around and ask everybody for what
their point of view is as an actionable
item to make this better and take all 50
thoughts and consolidate them and create
an output and so that's what we want to
challenge everybody to think about like
what's the actual item like if you're
the Lord of executing this fix the Lord
or the Lord s of fixing just saying of
executing this fix what is your point of
view
[Music]
[Music]
and I'm just been listening and I think
about things quite a bit about in a very
basic term of offense and defense I
think a lot of what we're talking about
tonight is defense
well reacting so battle the sexes Billie
Jean King did not commence the UTA to
change the rules they created the
Virginia Slims tournament but we're not
talking about the reality of that
situation which is they built a
different thing which they were in
control of and so whether it's my idea
of dictating or grassroots it's still
there's a gatekeeper we need to
understand real life I think everybody
here does and so instead of pandering to
the gatekeeper to me it's binary either
we go back to let's figure out who the
54 gatekeepers are and collectively put
pressure on them and/or create our own
thing and all go there I really just
genuinely believe it's a or B one of the
my favorite things about even coming to
events like this and then micro events
within events like this is meeting new
people so fun little thing on your way
out to the elevator I think there's a
lot of people here don't know each other
that should so one face that you don't
recognize and say hello I think would be
a really good tangible execution hope
you have a great CS and healthy 2018
thanks for coming
I know what you see in me you see that
full see the name you see enough to
believe in me you see the Sun but as he
and me
[Music]